Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
Est-ce que vous avez déjà ressenti
un sentiment d’impuissance
face aux enjeux écologiques ?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu l’impression
que votre action était
minuscule, invisible,
si les entreprises et les politiques
ne bougent pas ?
Que finalement ce n’était qu’une goutte
d’eau et que ça ne servait à rien ?
Moi aussi, je suis passée par là.
Il y a trois ans encore, ça me
rendait dingue de voir que,
malgré les alertes des scientifiques, ce
que moi j’essayais de faire à mon échelle,
rien ne bougeait.
Je fondais en larmes au repas de Noël
parce que je me sentais incomprise
quand j’expliquais
l’urgence de la situation,
et impuissante pour leur donner
envie de changer de comportement.
Alors je m’énervais
de l’inaction de ma famille,
je m’énervais de l’inaction des politiques
et de l’inaction des entreprises.
Et,
à un moment, je me suis dit :
« Et si, plutôt que de m’énerver,
j’agissais ? »
J’étais en école d’ingénieurs,
à Centrale Nantes,
et, plutôt que d’aller faire
un stage en entreprise,
j’ai lancé le mouvement « La Bascule ».
On était une cinquantaine à décider
de s’engager à plein temps
pour les transitions écologiques,
en habitant dans ce même lieu :
une polyclinique désaffectée
à Pontivy, en Centre Bretagne.
Et là-bas, notre ambition n’était ni plus
ni moins que de changer le monde.
Bon.
Je ne vais rien vous cacher :
on n’a pas changé le monde.
Mais, par contre, ce qu’on a
complètement transformé, c’est nous.
En tout cas, moi -
cette expérience, elle a changé ma vie.
Elle a changé ma vie, parce qu’elle
m’a permis de rencontrer des personnes
qui s’engageaient au quotidien
de plein de manières différentes.
Et ça m’a ouvert le champ des possibles
de tout ce que je pouvais faire.
Travailler dans un conseil municipal
et pourquoi pas être maire,
pour imaginer une ville sans
voitures et la redonner aux vélos,
intégrer les enjeux écologiques
au cœur de l’enseignement supérieur,
transformer une grande
entreprise de l’intérieur,
monter mon éco-lieu.
Apprendre à me servir de mes mains,
apprendre à cultiver la terre.
Être ingénieur.
Ingénieur dans la rénovation du bâtiment
ou ingénieur dans les low tech.
Bref, je ne me sens
plus du tout impuissante,
parce que, grâce à ces rencontres,
j’ai vu qu’il y avait
des centaines de façons d’agir.
Et...
je rêverais d’avoir plusieurs vies
pour pouvoir faire tout ça.
Et vous ?
Est-ce qu’il y a des personnes
qui vous inspirent ?
Ou des vies engagées qui vous font rêver ?
Est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà
vraiment posé la question
de comment vous pourriez
explorer ce pouvoir d’agir
dans votre métier, ou dans votre vie ?
Bon, d'accord.
Je suis diplômée d’une grande école,
alors vous vous dites peut-être
que c’est plus facile pour moi d’agir.
Ou peut-être qu’au contraire,
vous vous dites que c’est admirable,
ces jeunes diplômés qui
renoncent à une grande carrière
pour s’engager pour l’écologie.
Franchement, je n’en sais rien.
Je n’en sais rien si c’est plus
facile ou plus difficile pour moi,
mais je crois que ce n’est pas le sujet.
Le sujet, c’est qu’il est urgent d’agir.
Alors je ne sais pas si
je suis la bonne personne,
si je le fais de la meilleure manière,
mais juste, je le fais.
Alors peut-être que vous vous dites :
« Heureusement qu’elle est là,
cette génération de jeunes engagés. »
Mais moi,
j’aimerais que ça ne vous empêche pas
de vous aussi vous poser la question.
Parce qu’on a besoin de vous tous.
Alors j’aimerais vraiment que tout
le monde se la pose, cette question.
Quels sont tous les leviers d’action
que vous, vous pouvez activer ?
Vous.
Pas les autres.
Parce que si on attend que
ça vienne des autres, ça donne ça.
Ça donne des individus qui attendent
que le changement vienne
des entreprises ou des politiques.
Des entreprises qui disent
ne faire que répondre
à la demande des consommateurs,
donc que c’est la faute
des consommateurs et des politiques
qui rejettent
la faute sur les entreprises.
Ce sont les entreprises qui polluent.
Et voilà.
On est bloqué dans
ce triangle de l’inaction.
Et comme ça, on ne s’assure
que d’une chose :
c’est qu’on fonce droit dans le mur.
Alors, je crois qu’il est temps de nous
demander comment, en tant qu’individus,
en tant que citoyens, mais aussi en tant
que salariés, on peut le renverser,
ce triangle de l’inaction.
On n’a plus le temps
de juste se renvoyer la balle.
Il est temps de se focaliser sur
ce qui est dans nos mains, à nous.
Et je vous promets, cela peut
vraiment valoir le coup.
En tout cas, moi, cette posture d’action,
le fait de faire plutôt que de dire
aux autres « il faudrait faire »,
je crois que ça a changé ma vie.
Ça a changé ma vie, parce que
ça a transformé mon énervement
en énergie d’action.
Et agir, sentir que j’ai de l’impact,
cela me rend heureuse.
Heureuse, parce que
alignée avec mes valeurs
et heureuse parce que, ce que je fais
au quotidien fait sens pour moi.
Et, finalement, c’est un cercle
vertueux, parce que,
plus j’agis, plus je me sens heureuse,
et plus je suis heureuse,
plus j’ai envie d’agir.
Et donc, plus j’ai de l’impact
et donc, plus je suis heureuse.
Alors,
je crois que, pour moi, l’action,
c’est le meilleur remède
à ce sentiment d’impuissance.
Mais bon,
je ne veux pas dire que c’est facile.
Je pense que le pouvoir d’agir est un
peu comme un muscle, ça se travaille.
Et les vieilles habitudes,
elles peuvent revenir vite.
Par exemple, moi, après La Bascule,
j’ai dû retourner en cours
pour valider mon diplôme.
Et en cours, on étudiait
les réactions chimiques
qui se produisent
quand on brûle des énergies fossiles.
Et... scoop !
Ça émet beaucoup de CO2.
Et, donc, ça réchauffe le climat.
Alors nous, on se demandait
comment on pourrait réduire
un petit peu ces émissions de CO2.
Mais on ne se demandait pas
comment, en tant qu’ingénieur,
on pouvait avoir un rôle
dans la réduction massive
de notre consommation d’énergie fossile.
On résolvait un problème sans se demander
quelles en sont les causes
racines de ce problème.
Alors j’avais l’impression que notre
métier d’ingénieur finissait par être
de trouver des solutions qui étaient juste
des pansements sur des plaies béantes.
Cela me rendait dingue.
Et, en plus de ça, je voyais
mes camarades de promo
un peu perdus dans
leur recherche d’emploi.
Je me souviens notamment
d’une discussion avec Eugénie,
qui me disait qu’elle ne savait pas
comment trouver un métier
qui faisait sens par rapport
aux enjeux écologiques.
Alors moi, j'ai eu super envie d'aider
Eugénie, de lui parler de toutes ces vies
que je rêverais d’avoir pour lui donner
peut-être des envies, des idées.
Et, en discutant avec elle,
je me suis dit :
« Mais c’est dingue, ce sont
les écoles qui devraient faire ça,
qui devraient nous ouvrir
ce champ des possibles
de tous les métiers engagés
qu’on peut faire en tant qu’ingénieur. »
Et là,
une petite voix dans ma tête me dit :
« Bip-bip, Emma. Attention !
Tu es en train de retomber
dans le triangle de l’inaction.
Est-ce que, plutôt que de critiquer, tu ne
pourrais pas être force de proposition ?
Comment est-ce que tu pourrais
être actrice de ce problème ?
Aider les personnes en quête de sens,
en quête d’impact, comme Eugénie ? »
C’est comme ça que j’ai co-fondé Fertile :
une école de la coopération
et de l’engagement.
À Fertile, j’ai lancé un parcours
à destination des étudiants
et des jeunes diplômés
qui cherchent un métier
qui fait sens dans
la transition écologique.
Un parcours de cinq jours en immersion
dans un éco-lieu pour créer ses déclics
et ses inspirations que, moi,
j’avais pu vivre à La Bascule.
Et ce parcours, je l'ai présenté
à de nombreuses écoles.
Elles ont trouvé ça
génial sur le principe,
mais on a fait face à des gros freins,
notamment des freins financiers.
Alors on n'a pas réussi à vraiment
intégrer ce parcours dans les cursus.
Ça m’énervait parce que
je savais que ce parcours,
il répondait aux besoins
de nombreux étudiants.
Et vous, qu’est-ce que
vous auriez fait dans ce cas-là
pour continuer d’être dans l’action,
pour continuer d’être constructif ?
Moi, en tout cas, je n’avais pas envie
d’attendre des mois, voire des années,
que les écoles soient prêtes
à intégrer ce type de parcours.
Alors on a trouvé une solution.
Pas parfaite, mais une solution :
on a lancé le parcours en dehors
des cursus pendant les vacances
pour les étudiants et les jeunes
diplômés qui le souhaitent.
Ça fait maintenant un an qu’on l’anime
et ça a l’air de marcher, notre histoire.
Après le parcours, les étudiants,
ils disent avoir une immense motivation
pour dépasser ce sentiment
d’impuissance qu’ils avaient avant.
Ah oui, et Eugénie ?
Elle est venue au parcours et, après ça,
elle dit qu’elle s’est sentie
beaucoup plus légitime pour agir.
Aujourd’hui, elle est
consultante biodiversité.
Pourtant, ce n'était pas
sa formation de base.
Mais il y a de la place pour tout le monde
dans les métiers de la transition,
parce que peu de personnes y sont formées.
En parallèle de ce parcours,
en dehors des cursus,
on continue à discuter avec les écoles,
car elles sont de plus en plus
confrontées à cette problématique
de la quête de sens des étudiants.
Progressivement, on arrive à intégrer
des parties du parcours dans les cursus.
Une fois que Fertile a été bien lancé,
j’ai envie de continuer
d’explorer ce pouvoir d’agir,
à travers une autre vie engagée.
Celle de la transformation
des entreprises.
Aujourd’hui, je travaille chez Blue Choice
dans la formation aux enjeux
climats des grandes entreprises,
et, pour ça, je déploie un outil
qui s’appelle La Fresque du Climat.
C’est un outil collaboratif
pour comprendre les causes
et les conséquences
du dérèglement climatique,
et aussi pour donner envie d’agir.
Cet outil, il est à destination
de tous types de publics,
mais je le défends en particulier
dans les grandes entreprises,
au niveau des cadres dirigeants.
Bon.
Vous vous dites peut-être
que je suis bien naïve,
ou bercée d’illusions, de penser
que je peux, ou qu’on peut,
transformer ces grandes entreprises.
Mais moi,
quand j’anime pour des entreprises,
je n’anime pas pour des entreprises,
j’anime avant tout pour des gens.
Et les cadres dirigeants,
ce sont juste des gens.
Alors, quand ils établissent la chaîne
de conséquences que le dérèglement
climatique va avoir sur nos vies,
eux aussi, ils se sentent tristes,
ils ont peur pour leurs enfants,
ils se sentent coupables
et parfois impuissants.
Alors je ne sais pas
si on n’arrivera à transformer
les entreprises,
mais, par contre, j’ai confiance
qu’on puisse transformer des gens.
En leur montrant l’urgence
de la situation, mais aussi, et surtout,
en leur montrant qu’agir, ça peut
procurer beaucoup de bonheur.
J’ai souvent l’impression
que l’écologie ou l’engagement
sont vus comme des contraintes.
Mais moi, ce que je peux vous dire,
c’est que les personnes engagées
que je côtoie au quotidien,
je ne les sens pas contraintes,
je les sens alignées.
Je les sens animées par ce qu’elles font.
En fait,
je les sens profondément heureuses.
Allez !
Est-ce que vous aussi, vous n’avez pas
envie de l’essayer, ce cercle vertueux ?
Est-ce que vous ne voudriez pas vraiment
vous les poser, ces questions ?
« Comment je peux explorer
mon pouvoir d’agir ? »
« Comment est-ce que je peux être
acteur, actrice de ma vie ? »
Acteur d’une vie qui fait sens,
et qui fait joie.
(Applaudissements)